these cars obviously they're amazing and
they're so super designed and high-tech
you said a picture of the steering wheel
in your car first of all it doesn't look
like a steering wheel so that's the
spirit
so you hold on to that bit in that bit
when I joined this team I joined
Mercedes seven years ago and when I came
everything is about weight you know you
want to get the weight as low as
possible you want to make you know the
suit is as light as it can be the boots
are the helmet everything and I
redesigned the steering more when I got
there so it's the one thing that
particularly I can have quite a hands-on
you know opinion on and help design so
all the buttons where they are I helped
all of that and do you win it Tetris
when you play but what amazes me about
this I'll slow you down if I was in the
car without weight difference me in the
front 13 stone yeah so I'd be screaming
and crying but the weird thing about
this you look at all this high-tech
high-tech high-tech high-tech none of
these buttons operate air conditioning
no multi-millionaire driving
he deserves a see why don't you have I
wish I did why don't you have air
conditioning is it's all about weight so
you have to get rid of that there was
never a see and
[Music]
it's very breezy speeds you know 10
kilos of fuel in the car cost three
tenths of a second every circuit or lap
so if I'm a kilo overweight I can lose
up to two seconds in the race distance
so my weight is very important and also
during the way I lose up to four kilos
in the race in an hour and 45 minutes
yeah but this is because it gets so hot
isn't it so if you're in Singapore or
Malaysia or something yeah those ones
that killer but also because it's just
incredibly physical yeah and the g-force
that we pull when you go there mean the
things like on Rails
so when you're doing 150 180 miles an
hour and you turn the thing turns and
your body wants to go the opposite way
so you have to have a really good core
stability you can't be big and bulky if
you have your weight you know if I was
super Musti up here my weight would be
too high so to do lots of squats from
abut okay so to your driving weight yes
okay yes so actually so each year the
car is built to a certain weight but at
the beginning the year is heavy so they
were they asked me to be a certain
weight so a little bit lighter than
normal but then the car goes through a
weight saving process through the year
and but yeah I think what I though what
can you take away if it's why do you if
the cars do heavy yeah well they'll take
you know components off so if I'm if
yeah if the car is overweight they'll
just take certain devices off the car
which you know give the bike one second
what is the g-force that you pull up to
six times your body house tax jeez
that's crazy
[Music]
you